Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Monat ist schon äh bald vorbei, Datenvolumen schon verbraucht.
Ich kann nur mein Datenvolumen gar nicht verbrauchen.
Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertdreiunddreißig vom zwanzigsten Oktober zwanzig siebzehn. Nur ein Tag nach der letzten Folge.
Ja, großartig. Jetzt wird hier die Taktzahl erhöht. Ja, Thomas hatte.
Ja. Wir steigen.
Haben wir uns ja gerade schon drüber unterhalten, haben mich sehr gefreut diese Folge.
Steigern das Brutto-Podcast-Produkt.
Äh ah hier äh Daten.
Kannst dein Datenvolumen nicht verbrauchen.
Geht nicht. Kann ich nicht. Ähm weil ähm ich kann also mein äh ich habe ja keinen Empfang. Also es ist wirklich, ich bin.
Das ist wirklich, ich bin sowas.
Ich habe jetzt einfach so viele, ich glaube, ich ich kündige die längste Geschäftsbeziehung meines Lebens. Ich war seit.
W-Lan lief.
Ich war äh jetzt inzwischen die Hälfte meines Lebens äh bei bei Eplus unter Vertrag,
Ja, die Hälfte meines Lese oder einfach früh ein Handy gekriegt, ne? Sage ich aber nicht. Die Hälfte meines Lebens, ja.
Mal nachdenken. Wie lange bin ich denn da schon dabei? Ähm oh.
Ja ja, das war wie gestern, als du mit dem Nokia einundfünfzig zehn.
Also bei mir ist es noch nicht ganz die Hälfte des Lebens, aber es geht auch schon in die Richtung, merke ich gerade.
Also ich glaube, ich habe wahrscheinlich irgendwo anders noch längere Verträge. Äh irgendwie meine Eltern wollen ja irgendwann auch das ganze Geld zurück haben.
Aber na, also einer der längsten Verträge meines Lebens geht zu Ende, weil sich die Vertragspartei seit einigen Monaten nicht mehr im Stande sieht, ihren Teil,
erfüllen. Nämlich, wir haben da so einen Vertrag gemacht, dass ich ähm eine SIM-Karte kriegt, die ein Gerät reinstecke, so ein Funkgerät.
Und mit dem Funkgerät dann telefonieren und ins Internet kann.
Mhm, surfen.
Surfen zum Beispiel, ne,
und ähm der geht nicht mehr. Seit Jahre, also seit Monaten, ich bin und also jetzt wenn ich jetzt mal äh anfange zu raten, ja? Ich habe folgendes Phänomen. Also Hintergrund.
Zu sagen, von welchem Unternehmen wir reden oder? Also O2.
Plus ähm inzwischen also hat Otto hat die ja gekauft und hat dann gedacht, ey das ist doch bestimmt total einfach. Zwei Mobilfunknetze zusammenzulegen. Und da,
Ich wusste ja schon, dass es nicht ganz so einfach. Deswegen habe ich auch schon damit gerechnet, dass das ein paar Monate wird.
Aber das läuft doch jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren so oder nicht?
Nee, die haben die haben das bis heute nicht fertig. Also ich, ich erkenne mal die Phänomene benennen, die die mich plagen, ja. Geplagt haben, bald ist es ja vorbei. Ähm.
Also ich ich arbeite ja wie einige vielleicht wissen, im Bereich der IT-Security. Das heißt, wenn ich telefoniere, dann kommt das auch durchaus mal vor,
dass sich über,
Nicht unbedingt ein Staatsgeheimnis spreche und nix, wo wo man jetzt sagen würde, das darfst du auch am Telefon nicht besprechen, aber zumindest, wo man davon ausgehen möchte, dass man zumindest die durchschnittlichen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen eines Mobilfunknetzes
hinter sich weiß, wenn man telefoniert. Und was in dieser Branche total schlechten Eindruck macht, ne?
Ist, wenn das Gespräch auf einmal abbricht und beide Gesprächspartner jemand anderen hören.
Nein, wirklich? Ja.
Ich habe Zeugen.
Beide Gesprächspartner mit jeweils einer anderen Person sprechen,
So und das ist mir passiert. Ähm Thomas Lohninger, mit Thomas habe ich telefoniert. Ähm der ist mein Zeuge. Ähm Kai Biermann von Zeit Online, da haben wir über die Veröffentlichung von dem,
hier von dem Walheck gesprochen, ja?
C, weil ja.
Und auf einmal äh ist auf einmal, hörst du, hörst du so ein Rauschen, auf einmal ist da eine andere Person, was, was willst du? Warum hast du mich angerufen? So, ähm und noch weitere Personen, bei denen ich jetzt nicht disclosen möchte, dass ich mit denen telefoniert habe und vor allem nicht worüber.
Ja? So, das ist ein, also das ist ja ein so und das ist am laufenden Band passiert,
So, das andere, was die ganze Zeit passiert ist, ist, jedes Telefonat, jedes, je ein, jedes Telefonat bricht früher oder später.
Was zu der wunderschönen Situation geführt hat. Äh jetzt habe ich ja vor einigen Tagen mein O2-Vertrag gekündigt. Ähm,
Und wenn man das macht, dann geht ja die Maschine an mit dem äh wollen sich die sich das nicht nochmal anders überlegen. Also der du kannst sowieso einen einen O2-Vertrag nicht kündigen,
Geht nicht. Du kannst den zur Kündigung vormerken lassen,
dann musst du innerhalb von zehn Tagen dort anrufen und das bestätigen. Wo ich mich auch frage, was wo sind wir denn,
normalerweise werden Verträge schriftlich geschlossen und schriftlich gekündigt und die sagen, so ungefähr, die Kündigung bedarf der fernmündlichen Form,
ja? Also irgendwie auch totaler Scheiß, ja. Adresse, wo du einen Brief hinschreiben kannst, ich wollte ja eigentlich fristlos äh und außer,
Dingens außerplanmäßig kündigen, weil ich äh Grund zu der Annahme habe, dass äh dass das oder weil ich,
Das Vertrauensverhältnis zu diesem Anbieter als nachhaltig gestört betrachtet, seitdem äh vertrauliche Gespräche von mir unterbrochen wurden mit anderen. Das darf gar nicht gehen, ne. Das kann gar nicht sein, darf überhaupt nicht passieren. Nach allem, was ich und ich habe ja jahrelang in diesem Bereich gearbeitet.
Kann das gar nicht passieren. Es sei denn, du hast also eine massiv Verkackung, die,
gar nicht haben kannst, ja? Haben sie über Monate, ist das jetzt
immer wieder passiert, sodass ich inzwischen mein Mobiltelefon nicht mehr benutzen konnte. Ähm eigentlich nur noch fürs Internet, aber Internet geht ja genauso wenig. Deswegen konnte ich mein äh mein wunderschönes äh Volumen
Ich hatte ein ganz tolles Volumen, also wirklich richtig viel Volumen. Niemals, weil ich eben auch nur in der Nähe der Lage,
Volumen zu nutzen. Das habe ich denen ja auch immer gesagt, meinte, sie kriegen Herr Neumann, fünfzig Gigabyte. Ich sie können auch hundert machen, die kriege ich doch eh nicht.
Ja, okay, aber aber immerhin immerhin hätten sie die dann, ja gut. Also auch das äh nicht passiert, auf jeden Fall gestern. Also dann, dann fangen fängt diese Maschine an, wo sie dich anrufen, ne?
Erstens, machen die das offenbar, hatten die mich irgendwie dann auch wieder Vorlage, weil ich bin gar nicht dran gegangen
Ähm auf Wiedervorlage und Wiedervorlage ist bei denen morgens kurz nach neun.
So, dann ruft morgens um kurz nach neun, ruft einer bei mir an. Unangekündigt, ne? Das ist ja sowieso schon mal nicht, kannst du nicht machen, ne. So unangekündigt bei mir um neun Uhr morgens anrufen. Denn beim ersten Mal denke ich, es ist irgendwas Schlimmes, Schlimmes, Schlimmes geschehen,
Schrecke hoch, sag, was passiert? Was passiert?
Ich kriege ein Telefonanruf.
Sie haben o2 gekündigt. Ja, okay, habe ich sofort aufgelegt, ne. So.
Weiß ich schon, keine neue.
Richtig, endlich vielen Dank so. Können sie mir das nochmal schriftlich geben? Nee, reicht ja am Telefon, also schriftliche Kündigung. Auf jeden Fall ruft dieser Typ mir an und ich sehe an der Nummer, okay, das ist er jetzt und ich habe gedacht, jetzt bist du mal gnädig. Und habe gesagt, gehst du mal dran,
Hörst dir mal an, was sie vorzutragen hat. Ja, hallo,
O2 hier. Ähm ich wollte mal fragen, wieso sie denn den Vertrag gekündigt haben? Und ich sage.
Junger Mann. Nehmen sie sich kurz Zeit, ich erkläre ihnen das. Nummer eins, ihre Gespräche brechen andauernd ab. Und am anderen Ende höre ich nur, du.
Oh nein!
Gesprächsabbruch.
Und.
Und der Typ hat noch nicht mal wieder angerufen. Der hat noch nicht mal zurückgerufen.
Auweia, oh grandios.
Also liebe, liebe Freunde von O2.
Wow.
Es tut mir sehr leid äh viele Jahre war ich froh,
im im Unterschichtennetz zu sein und war stolz auf das Geld, was ich jeden Monat spare, aber,
Ich kann mir nicht mehr erlauben. Also das ist einfach im Kundenkontakt und auch im Kontakt mit Freunden, die andauernd denken, du hast aufgelegt, ja? Warum hast du denn aufgelegt? Ich habe mich aufgelegt, ich bin bei O2. Ach so.
Es geht nicht. Es geht nicht. Deswegen muss es jetzt leider ein Ende haben. Aber.
Jetzt zwischen den anderen beiden Premiumanbietern auswählen.
Ich sage jetzt nicht zu welchem ich gegangen bin ähm und man soll den Tag ja auch nicht vor dem Abend loben, weil noch hat O2 ja meinigfache Möglichkeiten.
Siehst du deine Nummer mit um.
Eben genau ich.
Wäre da, wenn die will da jetzt reingrätschen, ne? Oh! Dann fahre ich nach München. Ich weiß, wo die wohnen.
Blut.
Nee, also aber wirklich das mit diese ich wusste, ich habe einfach nur noch geweint.
Zwischen, dann, ich habe äh zwischenzeitlich habe ich mir eine Prepaid-Karte von einem anderen Anbieter geholt und habe darüber meine äh beruflichen Telefonate abgefackelt, weil es einfach nicht mehr ging,
Und ich habe dann mal, als das anfing mit diesen Unterbrechungen, ne,
habe ich, damit ich einen Beweis habe, äh Einzelverbindungsnachweise eingestellt und habe mir die, dann siehst du teilweise, wie ich achtmal hintereinander die gleiche Nummer anrufe, äh weil wir irgendwie telefonieren wollten.
Und die Leute einfach.
Und die Leute einfach nur inzwischen schon zu sagen, komm Linus, ist gut. Äh ne und dann dann haben,
und dann wollten wir über IP telefonieren. Ich blenke ja immer, dass es dann oder irgendwas gemacht habe, geht aber natürlich auch nur, wenn du zu Hause im WLAN bist. Weil wenn du unterwegs ist, ist der, ist das IP von denen, äh, genauso im Arsch wie, äh, wie das.
Wirklich, wirklich traurig und ich ich freue mich aber,
Ich freue mich, dass sich meine Mobilfunkrechnung jetzt im Zweifelsfall verdoppeln wird, aber ich dafür telefonieren kann. Da muss ich das eben leider in Kauf nehmen.
Okay.
Na ja.
Vielleicht wird mir reichen würde mir reichen,
Äh okay, wir wollten mal hier ähm.
Ja, das ist äh von den von den Störungen.
Ich habe mir jetzt irgendwie gedacht so und es gibt gerade so ein anderes Unternehmen, die auch meinen, sie müssten mich verarschen. Ähm ich bin mal gespannt, ob die äh ob die ob die weitermachen oder.
Auch im Telekommunikationsbereich oder.
Ja, ja. Ich bin da jetzt, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, wenn wer wer sich mit mir anlegt, der will im Pott, der landet im Podcast. Ey, also es ist unglaublich. Na ja, egal, also das wollte ich jetzt mal ganz kurz äh erwähnt haben, weil ich das sehr witzig fand.
Ja, meint, äh mal gucken. Also meine äh so im Frühjahr habe ich dann auch wieder so einen Termin für äh potenzielle Vertragsänderungen.
Früh übt sich äh ne, also früh anfangen, ne. Besser, Wetter jetzt als never,
weil äh da wird ich bin da noch gespannt, deswegen leite ich diese Geschichte ja jetzt schon ein. Also ich ich bin ja ich würde ja wirklich mir kaum vorstellen, dass das jetzt reibungslos über die Bühne geht,
mit Wechsel. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was sie sich da noch einfallen lassen. Ja, du wechselst auch.
Weiß ich noch nicht, als ich.
Ich als Kunden wärmen.
Jetzt wo du sagst, äh Verbindungsabbrüche hatte ich tatsächlich in letzter Zeit auch mal. Ähm man weiß ja immer nicht, an wem's so liegt. Ähm.
Ich weiß.
Ja gut, ähm müsste ich mal so ein bisschen mehr drauf achten, wobei dieses ich bin mit jemand anderem verbunden, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Wirklich habe ich viele Male. Ich habe das, ich habe das angefangen zu sammeln.
Glaube dir das, aber ich ich habe ich hab's halt jetzt so nicht gehabt und in der City
gibt's durchaus auch äh Netz außerhalb der City ist es natürlich äh problematisch und
Nur das Datenvolumen ist halt wie immer in Deutschland, das hatten wir ja hier auch äh gestern in der Sendung wieder mal ausführlich beklagt
dass das alles äh bekloppt ist und dass wir uns halt so äh Netzneutralitätsgefährden der Tarife eigentlich nur deshalb eintreten, weil.
Das nicht rausholen?
Weil einfach das Volumen künstlich begrenzt wird und das ist halt das.
Ich hatte bei O2 fünfzig Gig für irgendwie knapp über vierzig Euro. Das war ein guter Deal. Deswegen wollte ich den auch nicht aufgeben. Aber ich hatte zu keinem Zeitpunkt jemals diese fünfzig Gig,
Und ich konnte nicht telefonieren. Wenn das funktioniert hätte, wäre es ein Top-Deal gewesen. Und vielleicht kriegen das ja auch irgendwie hin,
Vielleicht kriegen wir's in zwei Jahren, kann ich ja vielleicht dann wieder zu denen zurückkommen. Aber also so die Dienstleistung muss schon erbracht werden.
Na ja.
Ich lasse mich gerne von den anderen Unternehmen abwerfen, wenn sie mir irgendwie ein Datenvolumen an äh bieten, was ich nicht ablehnen kann. Aber das, was ich bisher so gelesen und gesehen und gehört habe, äh kann man nicht nur äh ablehnen, da muss man dann einfach.
Da muss man laut lachen, ja natürlich.
Herzhaft drüber lachen. Äh das ist zwar ganz, ganz gut für meine Gesundheit, aber das war's dann auch.
Ja, ich habe, also für mich war die Situation jetzt einfach nicht mehr zu ertragen.
Vor allem, weil ich auch nie sagen konnte, hier ich habe in meinem Vertrag fünfzig Gig, ich konnte immer nur sagen, haha in meinem Vertrag, ne, da hätte ich fünfzig Gig.
Okay, äh was war, was äh gibt's Neues äh aus dem Bereich der Netzpolitik? Die Störerhaftung fällt.
Ja, angeblich gibt's gute Nachrichten.
Es gibt gute Nachrichten. Tim hat gerade extra in der Sendungsvorbereitung gesagt, lass uns das mal am Anfang nehmen. Das ist ein ein seltenes Kleinod. Dass wir was Positives zu berichten haben,
Das dritte Gesetz zur Änderung des Telemediengesetzes wurde jetzt auch durch den Bundesrat gebilligt und ähm damit äh so hoffen wir, Väter nun endlich die
Störerhaftung, ein sogenannter Störer,
ähm ist jemand, der die Tat nicht begangen hat, sie aber ermöglicht hat, indem er ein WLAN bereitgestellt hat,
Ähm und die Tat, wie sollte es anders sein, ist äh die einzige Tat, die im Internet äh wirklich mit drakonischen Strafen verfolgt äh und auch äh
sofortiger Strafe zugeführt wird und effizient verfolgt wird, nämlich die Verletzung des Urheberrechts, denn wo kämen wir denn da hin?
Ja, man muss ja auch an die Anwälte denken, die.
Genau, die Abmahn an.
Ne?
Die haben diese diese Drucker gekauft und die Kuvertiermaschinen und äh die mussten ja irgendwie auch mal abgehen. Also haben wir, glaube ich, hier auch in dieser Zeit lange genug in dieser Sendung lange genug behandelt,
ähm dass man sehr einfach,
sage ich mal, aus aus oder so sich die IP-Adressen raus rendert, automatisierte Abfragen macht,
nicht rausrennen da draus, äh dann automatisierte Abfragen macht, äh wer sich dahinter verbirgt und dann diesen Leuten automatisierte Abmahnschreiben,
mit bösen Drohbriefen und das Geld kassiert, das ist heute der Digitalisierung und Automatisierung sei Dank, ohne großartiges äh.
Nutzen von Menschen möglich. Man braucht dann vielleicht noch die, bei der Postangestellten Person, die diese äh Briefe zustellen, aber ansonsten kommt das Geld äh rein aufs Konto,
Und äh dieses äh wurde eben ermöglicht, weil der Bundesgerichtshof quasi äh diese Idee des Störers auch im Bereich des WLANs dann angebracht hat.
Und äh somit ein sehr beklopptes äh Geschäftsmodell, dass äh wirklich niemanden genutzt hat, ermöglicht hat, außer den wenigen,
wenigen Anwälten, die diesen Prozesse,
automatisiert haben. Es gab verschiedene Ideen dagegen vorzugehen. Es gab ja auch mal, ich glaube von Ilse Eigner dieses Gesetz, was die Abmahngebühren,
quasi deckeln sollte. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da rausgeworden ist, wie das wieder unterwandert wurde,
Ähm insbesondere gab's aber zweitausendvierzehn den ersten Entwurf von Seiten äh der Bundesregierung. Ich glaube,
Vom Wirtschaftsministerium, übrigens äh von der digitalen Gesellschaft schon lange davor. Es war eine der ersten Ernsthandlungen nach Gründung der digitalen Gesellschaft, einen Gesetzesentwurf vorzuschlagen, der die Störerhaftung,
beseitigt und damit das Provider Privileg, denn wenn man sich fragt, wie wenn man Leuten Internet gibt, ist man schuld, das würde ja auch für,
für Provider gelten und wäre zum Beispiel auch ein erklärter Grund, warum vielleicht gar kein Internet gegeben hat, aber nein, Previder haben das Privileg von dieser Störerhaftung befreit zu sein, Privatpersonen oder Kleinunternehmen,
hatten das nicht. Mit diesem dritten äh Gesetzveränderung des Telemediengesetzes äh das nun.
Verabschiedet wurde, wäre das,
Ist das auch nicht mehr der Fall. Wer hier gut zugehört hat, weiß, dass es zweitausendsechzehn einen ersten Anlauf gab, die Störerhaftungen abzuschaffen, der auch,
durchgegangen ist, der aber verbleibende Risiken hatte und ein Passwortschutz verlangt. Also man war nur von der Störerhaftung befreit, wenn man,
Ein Passwortschutz auf seinem Internet hatte, auf seinem WLAN hatte und das war etwas, was übrigens das äh ein EuGH-Urteil verlangt hatte. Ähm.
Egal, jetzt ist dieser zweite Entwurf durch. Man,
Die Juristen sind sich natürlich wieder uneinig, ist auch interessant, ne, dass sie nicht einfach mal ein Gesetz so schreiben kannst, dass es einfach klar ist. Man könnte ja auch einfach sagen, offenes WLAN, wäre ein offenes WLAN macht, kann nicht belangt werden. Thema durch. Jetzt kommt die Sache,
ähm Hotspotbetreiber können dazu gezwungen werden, bestimmte Seiten zu sperren,
wenn über sie das Urheberrecht verletzt wird, also etwa Falschharing-Seiten. Das soll aber allerletzter, allerletztes Mittel sein, nun ist das ja so, in der Juristerei, dass das allerletzte immer das einzige
ist. Also wenn wir Pech haben, wissen wir jetzt alle, net sperren äh auf unseren.
Naja, vor allem, ich meine, auf, wie hießen auch gleich die Webseite im Internet, wo das Urheberrecht noch nicht irgendwie verletzt wurde?
Ähm gibt's eine?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich.
Nee, wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Also, okay, ich dachte, es gäbe echt eine.
Bei dem Urheber es nein, das ist ja unmöglich, das Urheberrecht nicht zu äh verletzen und von daher können sie eigentlich auch gleich dicht machen dann, ne.
Also ich bin mal gespannt. Ich werde jetzt mal vorsichtig.
Ja, ich meine, ich habe eh also mit dem mit dem WLAN bereitstellen, immer gucken, also es gibt natürlich noch andere Risiken, das hatte auch damals schon Udo Vetter behandelt, ne, wenn es das wäre jetzt also das Abmahnding. Du hast noch irgendwie, wenn du Pech hast, halt das Problem,
dass irgendwelche äh wirklich Straftaten begangen werden äh über deinen Internetanschluss und du da äh in Probleme reinrassest, das bleibt davon
umbenommen, also mal schauen, wie sich das jetzt hier weiter entwickelt. Aber es klingt jetzt langsam danach, als könnte man einfach mal ein offenes WLAN machen
Aber lass uns da lieber nochmal vorsichtig sein, äh denn äh überall
lauert die Falle. Aber man könnte jetzt mal hier ein so viele Jahre,
gekämpften Kampf unter Umständen als vielleicht sogar ähm an seinem Ziel angelangt, beurteilen.
Das war's aber dann auch schon mit den guten Nachrichten.
Ja, weil gibt ja noch andere Gesetze, die in Kraft getreten sind, zum Beispiel unser schönes Netz DG.
Das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Das ist äh in Kraft getreten. Äh das ist der letzte der letzte Gruß den Heiko Maas uns noch zurückgelassen hat als scheidender.
Find's ja ein bisschen schade, dass es nicht Internetdurchsetzungsgesetz heißt.
Internetentsetzungsgesetz.
Durchsetzungsgesetz, weil dann hätte man ja zumindest dieser langjährigen These, dass sich das Internet nicht durchsetzt, äh entgegenhalten können. Doch, jetzt gibt's nämlich ein Gesetz dafür,
Bundesregierung beschließt, Internet setzt sich endlich durch.
Ähm ja der der komplette Name des Gesetzes ist ja glaube ich Besseren Durchsetzung der Strafverfolgung im Internet oder so
Das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt in Kraft. Wir es wurde ja noch in einigen Formen abgewandelt. Also es gab ja den ursprünglichen Protest ähm,
von Inhalte, Anbietern, von digitaler Gesellschaft, von verschiedenen äh Branchenverbänden,
Es wurden einige Dinge an diesem Gesetz geändert und ähm man darf jetzt abwarten wie es sich denn auswirkt. Leider.
Werden wir davon wenig sehen,
Denn spannend wäre jetzt, also die These war ja, es wird jetzt einfach zu viel geblockt und das Gesetz hat zu viele Anreize in Richtung Inhalte löschen und zu weniger Anreize in Richtung Inhalte drin behalten,
Ähm wir werden jetzt sehen, ob sich das in der oder man müsste jetzt in der Praxis sehen, ob das
wie sich das auswirkt, leider werden wir da aber wieder keine Transparenz und keine Statistiken drüber finden. Ähm insofern werden wir das, werden wir es dann wahrscheinlich im an einigen Einzelfällen in den nächsten Monaten noch einmal medial,
hysterisch begleiten können, was gelöscht wurde oder was nicht. Schön wäre es, wenn man jetzt irgendwie mal so eine äh so eine Statistik darüber hätte, so eine unabhängige und sehen könnte, okay, was wurde denn gelöscht? Die meisten Sachen, die gelöscht werden,
bekommen wir ja nie zu Gesicht. Deswegen werden sie ja.
Ich sehe eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob Facebook dem äh Informationsfreiheitsgesetz unterliegt und sich an das Gebunden fühlt.
Aber mal schauen, wie wie sich das also entwickelt,
Vielleicht allgemein könnt ihr euch ja eh mal ein bisschen zivilisierter im Internet verhalten. Übrigens auch in den Logbuch Netzpolitik. Bin ja froh, dass wir äh das Thema AfD jetzt nicht mehr in den Sendungen. Oh nein, habe ich AfD gesagt.
Keine Angst, das wird schon nochmal wieder zurückkehren, ne. Ja. So, dann äh scheint die Bundesregierung ein bisschen wackelig geworden zu sein, was so ihren Cyber äh betrifft.
Ja, als das als Dizitis gegründet wurde, wurde ja gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall werden wir äh schwachstellen, auf gar keinen Fall werden wir das Wissen über Schwachstellen zurückhalten. Keine Umständen,
Niemals werden wir das tun, gar keinen, gar keinen Fall.
Niemand hat die Absicht.
Niemand hat die Absicht, Schwachstellen zu horten. Äh jetzt äh setzt man sich da doch mal ein bisschen mit auseinander. Die SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete Saskia Esken hat eine kleine Anfrage äh an das Innenministerium
und die Antwort bekommen
das Problem, dass äh das Innenministerium setze sich gegenwärtig intensiv mit der Frage auseinander, wie denn,
mit dem Wissen über Schwachstellen überstellen umzugehen ist und man beabsichtige da einen Prozess zu konkretisieren,
Interessant äh oder das Beispiel hier wäre der in den USA äh bekannte Equitys process. Äh wo sich quasi dann die äh die.
Diejenigen, die den durchführen, anmaßend, quasi abzuwägen, was ist diese Schwachstelle wert,
was sie uns bietet im Rahmen der, was weiß ich, Kampf gegen den Terror.
Ähm und was ist diese Schwachstelle an Risiko für uns?
Oder für andere, ne, für äh betroffenen Nutzer. Ähm.
Leuchtet ein, ne? Also man man versucht die Abwägung zu treffen, okay, was ist der was wiegt äh wie schwer wiegt es, wenn wir alle Nutzer dieses Produktes weltweit dieser Schwachstelle ausgesetzt lassen, gegen,
unseren Vorteil, wenn wir diese Schwachstelle ausnutzen können. Ja, okay.
So funktioniert Politik. Man muss ab, man muss abwägen zwischen den Interessen aller Parteien.
Jetzt könnte man diese diesen gelobten ähm,
Mal irgendwie einer kritischen Beäugung unter äh unterziehen, wenn man sich nämlich anschaut, was äh für ein Theater bei uns veranstaltet hat, was ja eine Schwachstelle war, äh was ein Wurm war, der eine Schwachstelle benutzt hat, die aus dem,
Haushalt der NSA stammte und von anderen veröffentlicht worden war. Da kann man also sehen, mit welcher Verantwortung.
Und vor allem halt schon sehr lange sehr lange bekannt war.
Sehr lange in den Systemen schlummerte.
Hätte ja da schon vor Jahren was äh gegen tun können, aber hat man halt nicht. Das schlug ja wirklich genau zu dem Zeitpunkt auf den Tisch, als sie halt noch groß angekündigt haben, ah hier,
Kümmern uns jetzt mal, dass wir hier Überblick kriegen und so und dann.
Und vor allem sie in dem Fall wussten sie das ja seit Ewigkeiten, dass diese Schwachstellen in anderen Händen war?
Also ich finde die Formulierung, das Ministerium setzt sich mit dem Thema gegenwärtig intensiv auseinander. Da habe ich so einen Blick von,
Leuten, denen die Haare zur Berge stehen und schreien durch die mindestealen Flure rennen.
Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass sie,
einen fertigen Entwurf haben, den sie in sechs Monaten irgendwie auf den Tisch knallen, der einfach dahin gerotzt ist und äh der beinhalten wird, keine Ahnung, folgende geheime ähm,
Folgende dem Geheimschutz unterliegende Organisation trifft eine unanfechtbare Tatsachenentscheidung ohne jegliche Kontrolle oder Aufsicht. Und dann sagen sie, wir haben aber sechs Monate sehr intensiv,
haben wir uns damit auseinandergesetzt und in unsere vollständige Expertise einfließen lassen, parlamentarische Kontrolle ist hier,
gegeben. Wir haben ja das äh.
Experten befragt.
Wir haben Experten befragt.
Also ja, am Ende werden wir eine, also ne, muss man jetzt auch sagen, diese Organisation, die das dann macht, die muss ja
intransparent sein, ist ja klar. Äh weil wenn sie sagen würde, hey, wir haben folgende Schwachstelle und wir haben uns überlegt, wir halten die geheimen, oh, Scheiße, ähm das geht natürlich auch nicht. Ähm,
Aber aus ich bleibe dabei,
es wirkt immer schwerer
das Risiko für uns alle, denn wir sind ja hier dann die Spielbälle, ja? Wir, die unbescholtenen Bürger, die nichts zu verbergen haben, äh die dann diese Schwachstellen in ihren Systemen auch haben und die dem Risiko dieser Schwachstellen
Tag ein und tagaus. Ausgesetzt sind, bis sie irgendwann die Shadow Brokers ähm klauen,
und dann unsere Milka Produktionsanlagen damit kaputt machen.
Nein, die Shadow Rockers waren das natürlich nicht, aber ähm wir sehen, wohin die Reise geht. Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass die einzig sinnvolle Antwort ist,
Immer für alle sicher zu machen, Schwachstellen immer offen zu legen, Schwachstellen immer zu fixen und Schwachstellen nicht für sich geheim zu behalten.
Der Schaden, der darf über uns all das Risiko und der Schaden, der da um uns alle gebracht wird, ist immer höher.
Nicht äh ihr Wissen bei sich selbst behalten hat eine äh Gruppe aus Belgien.
Der ist äh in seinen FAQs sehr darauf bedacht, dass er der einzige ist. Äh ist keine Gruppe, er, er war das alles ganz alleine. Hat er nochmal extra die FAQ geschrieben?
Ist das auch so?
Und na, wenn er das sagt, gehe ich davon aus. Also das Paper hat zwei Autoren ihn und seinen Professor,
und er schreibt in sein FAQ, dass er den Professor nur dabei geschrieben hat, weil es sein Professor ist und er den dabei schreiben musste.
Was ja üblich ist an so Universitäten, ne? Ja, ja.
Ja, ja, genau, deswegen hat er das nochmal betont. Aber diese WF-Aku, warum schreibst du in dem PayPal? Ich glaube, wie dem auch sei, also er, ihm gebührt hier, äh, Ehre und Kritik,
Ähm beim Entdecken dieser Schwachstelle in den WLANs, die jetzt aber hier die ist ja mal abgegangen wie ein Zäpfchen.
Wurde äh.
Alle drüber geredet.
WLAN haben die Leute begriffen, das ist etwas, was jeder hat und was jeder braucht und jeder will.
Und ähm die Krypto, die er da angegriffen hat oder in der er ein Implementierungsfehler gefunden hat,
Ähm ist ja auch eine, die noch als sicher galt und gilt. Und übrigens auch weiterhin gelten wird, ne? Also ähm es gibt ja keinen, es ist kein fundamentaler Fehler in der.
Im Design gefunden worden, sondern in der Implementierung. Es geht also jemand hin, weil es wird ein Paper geschrieben und gesagt, äh es werde WPA,
Äh beziehungsweise es wäre WPA zwei und es sei folgendermaßen,
Und nach diesem Standard werden dann Implementierungen geschrieben und äh in vielen dieser Implementierung fanden sich eben Fehler. Und jetzt versuche ich,
mal zu erklären. Das wird spannend. Glaubst du wir können das? Ich kann das, glaube ich.
Naja, also der Nerdlevel wird jetzt auf jeden Fall äh steigen, egal, was du tust.
Also das Ziel von WPA ist, die Funkverbindung zwischen eurem äh Access-Point und eurem Endgerät zu verschlüsseln und zwar Ziel ist, ein außenstehender Angreifer soll,
gar keine Inhalte sehen, nichts, gar nichts. Der soll also das einzige, was er sehen kann, ist, da funkt etwas.
Genau, Bitbrei, wie erzeugen wir Bit Brei durch Verschlüsselung? Und äh das äh ein sehr,
Verschlüsselung genügt einem eigentlich sehr simplen Prinzip. Und zwar nimmt man einen,
geheimen Strom an Bits der scheinbar zufällig ist.
Und kreuzt diesen mit dem wirklichen Strom am Bits, den man äh übermitteln möchte. Die einfachste Variante wäre ähm,
quasi, dass beide verschlüsselte Parteien über einen bekannten,
geheimen Strom Bits verfügen, sagen wir mal, du und ich haben jeder das Gleiche ähm Gigabyte, random Informationen,
Auf unserer Festplatte liegen, dann könnten wir mit diesem Gigabyte einmalig ein Gigabyte verschlüsseln,
ja? Indem wir nämlich eine Operation,
anwenden, die diese beiden Gigabytes, also einmal die Informationen von der, die ich dir übermitteln möchte und die Information, die wir beide zur Verschlüsselung nutzen, miteinander kreuzen. Mit Hilfe einer Operation, die sich,
X-Or nennt, das exklusive oder.
Tollste oder der Welt.
Das Tollste oder der Welt und die der die X-Ohr Operation ist immer dann wahr, wenn die beiden Bits, auf die ich sie anwende, verschieden sind.
Also ich habe ja in diesem Fall meine mein mein eines Verschlüsselungs-Gigabyte, dass man in diesem Fall One Timepad nennt und meinen Datenstrom, also die die zu verschlüsselte Information und jetzt gehe ich für jedes Bit hin,
In den beiden, sage, okay, wir legen die jetzt nebeneinander. Jetzt gucke ich links in das One-Timepad, rechts in den richtigen, in die richtige Information und sage, wenn die beiden gleich sind, also eins eins oder null null,
dann ist das exklusive oder falsch, weil es ist ja kein oder, also gebe ich eine Null weiter,
Und wenn sie äh unterschiedlich sind, also null eins oder eins null,
dann ist mein exklusives oder war und ich gebe ein eins weiter. Und der Tim empfängt dann diese Information, nimmt sein One, nimmt sein OneTimepad, sein Gigabyte,
Legt das neben das Gigabyte, was ich ihm übertragen habe und wendet diese Operation wieder an. Ähm,
was dann wieder rauskommt, ist das, was ich übertragen habe,
Ähm so ist Verschlüsselung also reduziert auf das Problem, dass zwei Personen über einen Schein oder über einen zufälligen, scheinbar zufälligen Datenstrom verfügen.
Den sie mit ihrem wirklichen Datenstrom vergleichen. Jetzt kannst du aber nicht immer erst mal also dieses One-Time Pad-Beispiel,
Ist schlecht oder ist ist inpraktikabel, weil wir müssen vorher auf sicherem Wege dieses Gigabyte, was ich jetzt da mal Abitur äh ähm genommen habe,
austauschen. Und wir können das auch nur einmal verwenden.
Hast du jetzt einfach aus dem.
Nee, den habe ich gerade schon gesagt. Den habe ich gerade schon gesagt. Du hast nicht richtig zugehört. Ich habe den gerade schon mal gesagt.
Okay. Du hast ihn schon gesagt, aber du hast ihn noch nicht.
Genau, der heißt deshalb OneTime Pad, weil man's nur einmal machen kann. Ähm würde ich nämlich jetzt ein zweites äh Gigabyte wieder mit diesem One-Time Bett verschlüsseln, wäre ein Angreifer in der Lage, aus den zwei verschlüsselten Werten,
den Verschlüsselungswert, also das One-Time-Pad zu errechnen. Deswegen darf niemals,
Ähm das Gleiche, der gleiche Verschlüsselungsdatenstrom verwendet werden.
Jetzt haben wir gesagt, okay, wir haben ein One-Time-Pat, wir haben ein Gigabyte. Dieses Gigabyte hätte also den Nachteil, dass Tim und ich einmal auf sicherem Wege dieses Gigabyte austauschen müssen und wir dürften es niemals ein zweites Mal verwenden.
Also wir müssen uns immer wieder einen neuen Schlüssel ausdenken.
Wir müssen uns jedes Mal einen neuen Schlüssel ausdenken und das macht man folgendermaßen. Man hat nämlich eine ähm eine Funktion.
Die scheinbar zufällige Daten liefert,
und immer mit einem einfachen, sehr kurzen Schlüssel im Vergleich zu diesem Gigabyte ähm initialisiert wird. Und man nimmt also quasi diese Verschlüsselungsfunktion,
die nichts anderes tut, als ein pseudozufälligen Datenstrom bereitzustellen, initialisiert sie einmal,
und hat dann einen fortwährenden Datenstrom, weil man immer wieder das, was beim letzten Mal rausgefallen ist, wieder in diese Funktion gibt und so kann ich die den Bedarf an zufälligen Datenstrom immer decken, weil ich eine Funktion habe, die mir einmal initialisiert,
ähm diesen zufälligen Datenstrom immer weiter liefert.
Das läuft auf beiden Seiten. Gleichzeitig ab, sodass ihr immer wieder den Schlüssel.
Genau, das läuft einfach auf beiden Seiten gleichzeitig ab und quasi im Rahmen der Anmeldung hat man einmal den Pre-Share-Key, das ist das Passwort. Ähm und über den verschlüsselt tauscht man einmal einen aus.
Und ab dann verschlüsselt man. Was wunderschön ist, weil das ermöglicht, dass ähm,
dass man also Datenströme ähm immer wieder anders verschlüsselt, das heißt auch jemand, der im Nachhinein an diesen Schlüssel gekommen ist
ist nicht ohne weiteres in der Lage diesen Datenstrom wieder zu entschlüsseln. Aber da wird's jetzt zu kompliziert und geht in die Tiefen von
WPR zwei rein. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, bei diesen ganzen X-Operationen, man darf zu keinem Zeitpunkt jemals die gleiche Information zweimal übertragen,
mit unterschiedlichen Schlüssel. Ähm und erst recht nicht den gleichen Schlüssel zweimal nutzen. Ähm.
Und genau das ist hier ähm kaputt in diesem äh in diesen.
Äh in der in in vielen Implementierungen von WPA. Man nennt diesen Schlüssel äh diesen Initialisierungsschlüssel auch nons.
Damit man weiß echt nur einmal benutzen.
Äh ich wäre jetzt sehr im Detail drinsteckt, wird erkennen, dass sich einige Details übersprungen habe, aber der entscheidende Punkt ist, man darf niemals eine Nons zur,
Machen. So ein Twice.
So und jetzt machen die ähm.
Die Angreifer gehen also jetzt hin und nutzen einen Prozess, der äh also wenn ihr jetzt von einem von einem WLAN
empfangt zu dem anderen geht, dann müsst muss ja trotzdem irgendwie eine Übergabe erfolgen, ja? Also wenn man jetzt in einem, wenn man ein WLAN hat mit mehreren Antennen.
Ähm da muss dein Übergang entscheiden, pipapo ist, glaube ich, geht nicht so, geht ein bisschen zu sehr ins Detail. Entscheidend ist der Angriff funktioniert dadurch, dass man ähm,
Eine Empfangsbestätigung des WLAN-Kleiens auf dem Weg zum WLAN-Router abfängt, bevor sie den WLAN-Router erreicht,
WLAN weiß natürlich nicht, dass seine Empfangsbestätigung nicht angekommen ist und verschlüsselt dann eben weiter seine Daten mit den Schlüssel, den er ausgehandelt hat.
Jetzt verstreicht eine Frist, weil der Router die Empfangsbestätigung nicht bekommen hat und dann schickt er ähm,
ein, das scheinbar verloren gegangene Paket erneut. Ja, also der der WLAN der der der Kleinsendet die ganze Zeit Pakete und sagt, alles super, alles super.
Der Router ähm erwartet eine äh Empfangsbestätigung, kriegt die beim ersten Mal nicht, weil die Angreifer, die weggeschluckt haben?
Und der Klein denkt sich aber ja alles super und jetzt kriegt er auf er hat also weiter verschlüsselt neue Initialisierungsvektoren genutzt und jetzt kommt der kommt auf einmal der Router und sagt ey,
hier ist das Paket nochmal, du hast nämlich den Empfang nicht bestätigt. So, jetzt sagt der Kleine, oh krass, ich war voreilig, ich habe,
Schon weiter verschlüsselt, immer wieder neue Pakete genommen, immer wieder meine Funktion neu mit den letzten, mit der letzten Maus, mit einer neuen Nonse installisiert und sagt, oh fuck, jetzt muss ich quasi zurückspringen,
Auf den letzten Status, den ich mit dem Router hatte. Ich muss also meine Kryptographie mit dem Router neu synchronisieren.
Ähm also einen Prozess durchführen, der Key Reinstallation heißt. Wir müssen uns neu darauf einigen.
Und ähm was nun bei vielen Kleinen passiert, ist die verschlüsseln Daten noch einmal mit der gleichen Nonsen.
Und damit hat der Angreifer schon gewonnen.
Ähm insbesonders interessant ist das in dem in dem WPA äh Treiber WPAC, der unter Lynox Anwendung findet.
Wenn du ganz früher Unterlinums WLANs installiert hast, dann musstest du auch echt immer nochmal installieren, weil alle noch auf WEP waren
Ein ganz fürchterliches Stück Software, kann ich nur sagen, will man gar nicht reinschauen, hätte aber mal jemanden machen sollen, denn der WPA-Sublikant hat in
hat die im im im Standard von WPA steht. Passt mal auf, wenn ihr den Schlüssel einmal benutzt habt, überschreibt den am besten im Speicher mit null, damit ihr den nie wieder verwendet, ja? Und dann hat der WPA-Subliquin,
gesagt, jo machen wir. Und bei der Key Reinstallation nimmt er dann einen Schlüssel nur aus Nullen,
Was bedeutet, dass diese X-Ohr Operation für alle Daten absolut äh vorhersagbar ist. Das heißt, in dem Moment ist es halt trivial und du kannst sofort mitlesen.
Ähm da,
Also das, ne, wenn du also das X-Or mit mit wenn du in dem Moment nicht hätten, auch einfach nur eins nehmen können oder null, eins, null, eins, ist völlig egal. Ähm, es ist klar, was es ist ein statischer Initialisierungsvektor und das ist halt alles Mist.
So kann man also in eine bestehende WLAN-Verbindung eingreifen und dann äh bis zu dem Punkt kommen, dass man die also ähm mitschneiden und,
auch aktiv manipulieren kann.
Wobei das ist jetzt, glaube ich, an der Stelle auch mal ganz wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, dass ist es denn eigentlich auch? Also man.
Genau, das ist nämlich eine Session Verschlüsselung, von der wir die ganze Zeit.
Also es ist also ein Mithorchen möglich, während einer laufenden Verbindung, indem man
in die quasi reinhustet und äh quasi den Verschlüsselungsmodus aus dem Tritt bringt, auf eine Art und Weise, dass es dem Mithorcher dann möglich ist, die tatsächlichen Daten, die übertragen werden dort,
abzufangen. Es ist nicht so, dass man danach irgendwie den,
eigentlichen äh Ursprungsschlüssel, dieses WLANs erfährt und sich immer einbuchen kann und dann jemand im Nest hat, sondern es ist sozusagen nur ein mit Hören einer aktiven,
Verbindung möglich und von daher ist das Problem schon mal begrenzt und äh man muss halt auch sehen,
Das Ganze betrifft halt nur die Verschlüsselung in der Luft. Äh wenn irgendein Provider abgehört wird auf dem Kabel, dann.
Dann ist ein Problem sehr viel größer.
Ja, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann fällt das ohnehin weg und äh dann sind die Daten ohnehin da. Also es ist sozusagen, die Frage ist, wer ist jetzt hier der Angreifer und wer kann daraus einen potentiellen Nutzen haben? Das ist halt eine Methode
WLAN-Verschlüsselung äh abzugreifen. Das heißt, wenn man an Netze ran will, die vielleicht nicht öffentlich sind und wo man nicht äh den anderen Weg abfangen kann und das ist jetzt ein besonders lohnenswertes Ziel, dann mag es äh äh für einen Angreifer
sinnvoll sein, diesen Aufwand zu treiben und dann ist es eben möglich, wenn sich die Betroffenen Geräte eben nicht richtig verhalten. Jetzt.
Was hier viele tun.
Was äh sie jetzt sehr viele tun, man kann davon ausgehen, dass für populäre Aktuelle Systeme äh relativ schnell jetzt auch Lösungen kommen. Teilweise sind sie auch schon äh gekommen
und ähm man kann aber auch davon ausgehen, dass eine bestimmte Kategorie von äh Geräten, die schon lange keine Softwareupdates mehr erhält
äh hier äh ne, insbesondere die hier mit diesem äh ausgestattet sind. Da wissen wir ja, das ist dann halt so ein Problem. Das heißt, es wird eben ähm,
bleiben, ne? Aber.
Nur einen einen Aspekt. Du hast gerade gesagt,
Es ist nur das Mithören möglich. Du kannst auch das Ding zu einem vollständigen Mittelangriff ausweiten. Wenn du nämlich
In dem Moment, wo du einmal diese Verschlüsselung geknackt hast, sprichst du hier sie ja auch selber und kannst damit, und das demonstriert er auch in diesem Video
dann das neue WLAN sein, ja, das heißt, du kannst dann einen Manage, du kannst dann den Access-Point vollständig nachemolieren, kannst Internet bereitstellen, hast dann,
ganzen Möglichkeiten, die du als Mittel oder als Router sowieso hast, äh also, was weiß ich, es ist anwenden,
was weiß ich, DNS anfragen. Also dann bist du einmal
in der Position, die halt jemand hat, der ein Netz gibt. Ähm weshalb er dann auch Beispiele äh äh hier zeigt, wo er dann eben äh HTPS ausschaltet und dann äh Passwörter klaut.
Aber er demonstriert das halt mit ohnehin unsicheren, hat
PS-Webseiten und daher das BSI dann relativ schnell an die Öffentlichkeit ging und meinte äh Leute Gefahr, ihr müsst jetzt irgendwie äh die nächsten Wochen dürft ihr kein Online-Banking mehr verwenden. Das ist natürlich Blödsinn. Äh man sollte kein Online-Banking verwenden
wo die Bank ihre Webseite äh schlecht gesichert hat. Das sollte man aber sowieso nicht tun, ganz unabhängig von diesem Back. Und äh da ändert sozusagen jetzt dieser äh Kram nichts. Aber das.
Mir ist auch tatsächlich kein Online-Banking äh bekannt. Das kann sein, dass es welches gibt, aber es sehe mir ist nicht bekannt, dass es einen Online-Banking-Anbieter gibt, der sein SSL nicht vernünftig
konzipiert hätte. Ja, also dazu gehört eben, dass man äh Hyper, Text,
Transportpolicy und solche Header alle anhat, sodass sich eigentlich, wenn du einmal Online-Banking mit einem Gerät gemacht hast, dann sollte sich dieses dieser Browser weigern, jemals wieder.
Mit diesem mit dieser Bank unverschlüsselt zu sprechen,
ja? Und äh das wird äh diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind alle noch intakt, also Online-Banking über WLAN,
kann man in der Regel noch machen. Ähm
kommen ja auch noch weitere Schwierigkeiten dazu. Äh ne, man bräuchte dann als Angreifer noch die Tannen und so. Da sind Angriffsszenarien immer möglich, geht immer alles irgendwie, aber das ist jetzt wirklich nicht die größte Sorge, die man hat.
Zumal es bisher noch keine der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stehenden Implementierung davon gibt. Das heißt, bevor das jetzt jemand nachgebaut hat, geht auch nochmal eine Woche ins Land. Äh und bis dahin haben wir hoffentlich,
Für die Geräte, äh die man zum Onlinebanking nutzen kann, ähm auch Updates.
Genau, weil wenn wir jetzt nochmal kurz zurückblickt auf das, was wir jetzt äh zuletzt äh gesagt hatten zum Thema Zero Days, ne, man stelle sich jetzt mal vor, äh
Belgier hätte das jetzt nicht auf diese Art und Weise veröffentlicht mit äh entsprechender Webseite noch dazu und Pipapo und entsprechenden äh Rummel. Ähm sondern hätte das jetzt irgendwelchen Shadow Organisationen zum Kaufangeboten
und.
Da hätte er sicherlich Geld für bekommen.
Gibt's sicherlich Geld für, das wäre dann in der Schublade äh verschwunden und es hätte keine Patches gegeben für die populären, aktualisierenden Betriebssysteme
dann wäre sie wieder eine weitere Sicherheitslücke, die alle potenziell eben in Gefahr bringen kann, einen Moment, wo man sich eben zumindest halbwegs in Sicherheit,
wiegt auch wenn man sich ja selber eigentlich nie in Sicherheit wiegen sollte.
So viel zum Wählern.
So viel zum äh WLAN, aber wir haben noch was mit Krypto, weil es gibt ja auch andere Möglichkeiten. Kryptographie aus der Spur zu bringen. Äh Programmierfehler äh sind vielfältig und.
Programmierfehler sind vielfältig. Ich werde das.
Kommen wir den besten Chipherstellern vor.
Ja, da gibt's also eine ähm eine Veröffentlichung von Forschern der Universität von Masarik in der tschechischen Republik. Ähm und zwar haben sie eine mathematische Schwachstelle,
Eines Algorithmuses zur Primzahlengenerierung verwendet. Ich will jetzt hier nicht äh Kryptographie Einführung in die Kryptographie machen,
aber ähm Primzahlengenerierung ist sehr wichtig äh für das Erstellen von,
RSA, Kryptographie Schlüssel und das ist dann wichtig, wenn man vor allem von so Hardware-Security-Models oder Trust
Trusted, Plattform Model spricht, also kleinen Hardware-Security-Talkens. Wie sie zum Beispiel in UB-Keys,
zu finden sind. Die haben dann bei den haben gesagt, ach geil, für die, für die Generierung von RSA-Schlüsseln
nutzen wir einfach hier diese vom BSI Zertifizierte Community Funktion, die Infinion vor zehn, zwanzig Jahren mal geschrieben hat und dann sind wir auf der sicheren Seite,
Voll geil? Und dieser Angreifer, äh diese Forscher haben also jetzt eine,
Möglichkeit gefunden, wo man aus dem ES aus dem öffentlichen Teil des ESA-Schlüssels mit moderatem Aufwand den geheimen Teil des ESA-Schlüssels.
Errechnen kann. Beim fünfhundertzwölf bitlanden Schlüsse, den man eigentlich sowieso nicht mehr verwenden sollte, braucht man dafür zwei CPU-Stunden. Das heißt, äh ungefähr sechs US-Dollar Cent,
Ähm bei tausendvierundzwanzig Bitchlüsseln, die noch relativ häufig in Verwendung sind, braucht man dafür,
knapp hundert CPU-Tage, das heißt da ist man bei ungefähr vierzig bis achtzig Dollar, denn man kauft diese CPU-Tage sind ja parallelisierbar, das heißt zwei CPUs brauchen fünfzig Tage äh und die Amazon braucht dann eben achtzig Dollar oder sowas,
um das an einem Tag zu machen. Also,
So viel zur Skalierung. Äh bei zweitausendachtundvierzig Schlüssel ist man dann immerhin bei einhundertvierzig CPU-Jahren, also bei einem,
höheren fünfstelligen Betrag, ähm der aber trotzdem, wenn man da, wo RSA Schlüsse zum Einsatz kommt, eben absolut zu
billig ist und zu einfach ist, als dass man diese Schüssel weiter verwenden sollte. Ja, deswegen gibt's jetzt ein schönes Update für diese Key Generation Function, die das BSI zertifiziert hat und die Infineon seit vielen Jahren in viele Produkte,
gebracht hat und das scheint mir jetzt irgendwie das größere Problem zu sein, ehrlich gesagt. Da haben wir eine Schwachstelle, wo viele Unternehmen dann drauf hängen bleiben, gerade weil es so hart wäre
Talkens sind, die jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres äh sagen, ey update mich mal und da werden wir die nächsten Jahre dran zu knacken haben.
Gibt mir auch nochmal die Gelegenheit, vielleicht ein,
einen uralten Podcast von mir zu äh pluggen, der noch so ein bisschen unterpubliziert ist, der ist zwar noch online, aber schwierig zu finden, wenn man nicht drauf verlinkt, was ich dann äh tun werde
Ich habe nämlich vor langer, langer, langer Zeit äh hatte ich ja auch mal eine englische Interviewserie gestartet, mich so mit allerlei Hackerfolk äh
unterhalten. Das lief dann damals noch unter Chaos, Radio International.
Aha.
Ja doch, aber da da äh die verlangen auch vieles, die wieder aufgenommen wird.
Ähm,
Ja, also könnte ich mal wieder, müsste ich mal überhaupt mal ein bisschen mal republizieren, ist ein bisschen verloren gegangen, weil ich dachte, ich mache mal so eine internationale Sektion, dass ein bisschen eingegangen, dann ist das so in zäh je übergegangen und seitdem liegt es nur noch rum, aber ich habe mein Interview mit Witfield,
gemacht, genau und zwar vor mittlerweile äh elf Jahren und äh das hat äh,
der aus dem Key Exchange, der quasi die Basis ist für genau diesen ganzen Schlüsselaustausch, äh, Klimmbim, den wir hier gerade so ausführlich besprochen haben, also die Grundlage auch für RSA und so.
Das gut erklären?
Er hatte ein bisschen Einblick in die ganze Geschichte. Ich lies gerade selber mit Interesse hier meine Zusammenfassung und äh
ich muss mir das, glaube ich, selber nochmal anhören, weil wir da auch viel über so Hackerkultur und so weiter gesprochen haben. Ich bin da irgendwie nach Prag gefahren, weil da auf unserem Event da Lieferung und habe ihn dann im Hotelzimmer irgendwie.
Großartiges Ding.
Na ja, ähm so viel also dazu. Aber jetzt, jetzt wird's erst richtig spannend. Jetzt wird's unterhaltsam, ja.
Unterhaltsam. Bisher war ja alles noch nicht so unterhaltsam.
Also, ich meine, seit einigen Jahren ist ja klar, dass man dem Russen nicht trauen kann.
So so lautet der aktuelle Zeitgeist zumindest. Zwanzig Jahren, wenn wir sie alle wieder ganz lieb haben, dann wollen wir lachen.
Der Russe. Äh so und äh jetzt also hier die Story äh entfaltet sich ein bisschen interessant. Ähm.
Und zwar gibt es einen ähm Antivirenhersteller,
mit dem Namen Casperski. Ist vielleicht vielen von euch auch bekannt. Habt ihr vielleicht, wenn ihr Windows-Geräte nutzt, habt ihr den vielleicht sogar da drauf. Und ähm das ist einer der großen Antiviren,
Softwarehersteller der Welt,
und den wird natürlich wie jeden anderen Russen auch unterstellt, dass er mit dem russischen Geheimdienst zusammenarbeitet. Ähm.
Was stimmen kann oder auch nicht?
Kann sein, kann nicht sein. Folgendes passiert, ein NSA-Mitarbeiter ähm,
verstößt gegen die seine Dienstanweisung und nimmt irgendwie NSA Myware inklusive
also inklusive Anleitung und so weiter irgendwie mit nach Hause und speichert sie auf seinem privaten Laptop,
und benutzt auf diesem privaten Laptop, weil er Angst hat vor Viren? Gasperski,
Kaspersky Antivirus äh,
findet diese Software und sagt, komisch? Könnte Myware sein.
Schicke ich mal zur Analyse nach Hause in das Kasperskill Labor,
Übrigens all das ähm äh Funktionalität laut Beschreibung des Produktes, ja, also dafür sind die da. Ähm,
also das weiß man, dass sie das tun. Dafür hat Kaspersky diese ganzen Myware Forscher irgendwo sitzen. Das ist das Versprechen, was sie haben. Sie müssen ja auch Forschung betreiben,
macht jeder andere äh Virenscanner auch so, äh dass er also ähm nach verdächtigen Dateien auf der Festplatte sucht.
Und äh so gelangt also durch diesen äh Verstoß gegen die Dienstanweisung dieses äh NSA Mitarbeiters. Kaspersky an diese NSA-Mywe. Und guckt sich die an und sagt, äh das eine
Ist ja schlecht, ne. Und ähm interessanterweise.
Machen wir denn das zum Vorwurf? Geht aber noch ein bisschen weiter die Geschichte. Die NSA verbietet also jetzt äh hatte sowieso,
Ähm Kaspersky verboten bei ihren Mitarbeitern unter anderem deshalb
weil sie selber auch immer antivieren exployen, wenn sie ähm Systeme übernehmen
Also ein Antivirus ist ein eine Software, die auf dem Computer läuft und das, was sie verspricht, nämlich alle Programme zu kontrollieren, auf schädliche Aktivität vor der Ausführung zu prüfen. Ähm,
quasi wenn das Programm
versucht, in irgendwelche Systemeinstellungen zu gehen, eine Warnung zu geben und all das kann ein Virenscanner nur machen, wenn er sehr tiefe äh Befugnisse im System hat
also sich sehr tief in das System, in das Betriebssystem einnistet. Deswegen ist es sehr lustig, wenn man einen Virenscanner explodiert, weil man dann
sehr große Systemprivilegien hat und die ausnutzen kann. Das heißt, man hat Zugriff auf alle Dateien. Man hat Zugriff auf den Speicher, man kann sich alles anschauen, was das Betriebssystem so macht. Das heißt, die das optimale Ziel für eine,
oder für einen Trojaner, ist der Virenscanner selber. Weshalb viele Leute eben auch keine Virenscanner benutzen.
Weil könnt ja böse enden.
Also aus diesem Grunde, also die NSA sagt, erstens wollen wir nicht, dass fremde Virenscanner unsere Sachen finden,
Zweitens wissen wir, dass wir selber Schwachstellen in Virenscanner nutzen und ausnutzen. Deswegen, liebe Freunde, installiert ihr keine russischen Virenscanner, weil wir wissen ja, dass die unsicher sind. Das ist die eigentliche Begründung, warum die NSA das verboten hatte. Ähm.
Also bestimmt auch nicht nur russische sondern überhaupt keine Virenscana sozusagen.
Das weiß ich nicht genau also Kaspersky auf jeden Fall ja aber auf jeden Fall im September jetzt sagte das Department of Homeland Security dann,
vollständig überall in allen Behörden müssen ähm,
Innerhalb von sechs Monaten Casper SGD installiert werden, denn die Software, wir haben herausgefunden, die Software umfassen in der Zeitzugriff,
Nein, hör auf und ähm.
Und kann außerdem äh explodiert werden. Ach was, so, ne,
Auch das irgendwie ein ein sehr großer äh Captain, ob wir es an dieser Stelle. Sagen aber die Sorge ist, dass der russische Geheimdienst ähm diese Funktionalitäten von Kaspersky
ausnutzen könnte, also die äh die die Sorge ist hier, wir befürchten, dass das Unternehmen Kaspersky.
Wissentlich oder unwissentlich mit dem russischen Geheimdienst zusammenarbeitet? Jetzt ist die Frage, woher wollt ihr das denn wissen? Stellt sich raus.
Jetzt gehen wir ein bisschen in der Zeit zurück,
Zweitausendfünfzehn hatte Kaspersky zum ersten Mal die NSA so ein bisschen unglücklich gemacht, denn sie haben bei einem ihrer Kunden mit dieser Funktion, über die jetzt grade,
Diese NSA-Mywe, mutmaßlich gefunden wurde
Die Equation Group entdeckt. Also bei einem ihrer Kunden Myware gefunden, das Ding dann irgendwie okay, zack, schick mal nach Hause. Wir untersuchen jetzt mal hier diese Datei. Die ist doch etwas sehr komisch. Und da haben sie diese
Equetion Group myware gefunden. Also eine modulare myway. Wir haben damals auch, glaube ich, ausführlich in Lokbuche darüber
berichtet die der NSA zugeordnet wird aufgrund der Funktionalitäten die sie hatte aufgrund der Ziele bei denen Kasperski sie gefunden hat
Das heißt, zunächst einmal zweitausendfünfzehn hat Kaspersky die Meriten
Eine NSA-Mywe gefunden zu haben und diese veröffentlicht zu haben. In dem Moment ist natürlich klar, sobald du irgendetwas gegen gegen NSA-Geheimdienste, gegen amerikanische oder Five-Eis-Geheimdienste machst, ist klar
wenn sich wenn die sich nicht selber melden, meldet sich innerhalb kürzester Zeit Hans-Georg Maaßen und sagt,
hier das ist ein russischer Spion, ne? Genauso wie Edward und so, ne, alles russische Spion. Spätestens seitdem haben sie also damit zu kämpfen.
Dummerweise entdecken sie dann auch Kurz
kurz darauf bei sich selbst, die nächste in ihrem eigenen Lab äh die getauft wird, Du QQ2
und die entscheidende Ähnlichkeit zu einem äh Trojaner hat, der äh vor viele Jahre zuvor schon unter dem Namen Stuckset
bekannt wurde und der allgemein Israel und den USA zugeordnet wurde und damals ähm,
Zum Angriff auf das iranische Nuklearprogramm genutzt wurde dummerweise aber eine Verbreitungsroutine hatte, die dazu führte, dass auch irgendwo anders auftauchte und dann eben äh später entdeckt wurde.
Mit anderen Worten, vor drei Jahren ungefähr, hatten israelische Geheimdienste schon Kaspersky gehackt,
Ähm hat das bemerkt,
Und jetzt jetzt scheint es aber so und da wird's jetzt Gerüchteküche, dass die der israelische Geheimdienst, als er Kaspersky gehackt hat, gemerkt hat, dass er nicht der Einzige ist,
der da drin sitzt, sondern dass der russische Geheimdienst ebenfalls bei Kaspersky äh drinsitzt,
und alle diese Software von Kaspersky also nutzen, um Leute zu,
und die Formulierung, die ihr fällt, dass äh Kaspersky wie eine Art Kugel über die Computer von Kunden suchen könnte,
und dass sich unter diesen Kunden eben mehrere US-Behörden äh befinden. Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, wie kommt es, dass die,
Der israelische Geheimnis, das schon seit drei Jahren weiß, heute aber auf einmal erst dieses große Theater losgeht, das äh irgendwie weltweit äh gesagt wird.
Ähm Kaspersky sei also von denen von von dem FSB oder von wem auch immer unterwandert.
Nun ja, erstens, diese ganzen Geschichten über den israelischen Hacks sind äh sind eher äh unanonyme Quellen, die also dass die Israelis behaupten, sie hätten vor drei Jahren äh die Russen bei Kaspersky entdeckt, das sind alles anonyme Quellen,
Zweitens, ähm,
Es ist offenbar billig und angenehm jetzt auf Kaspersky einzudreschen, wenn man die NSA ist, weil das jetzt ja schon zumindest der zweite Fall ist,
wo äh Kaspersky, der NSA irgendwie in die Quere kommt, nämlich einmal durch das Entdecken der und jetzt durch den zweiten Fall, wo der Mitarbeiter äh versagt,
Dienstaufschriften, äh Dunstdienstvorschriften verstößt und deswegen auch sein Privatrechner bringt,
Und auffällig ist natürlich, dass das Problem von Kaspersky hier in keiner Form aufschränkt, sondern auf alle antivieren, weshalb eben auch einige äh überhaupt keine Antiviren benutzen.
Und dementsprechend natürlich dann auch angreifbar sind wiederum, weil manchmal tut diese Software ja dann auch was Sinnvolles.
Wer aber keinen Antivirus benutzt, ist eben auch angreifbar, wenn er sich eben
nicht vernünftig verhält. Also interessante, ein interessantes Spielfeld. Ich finde das nur echt schön, wie diese Geheimdienste da
gegenseitig überall drin hängen und dann am Ende irgendwie Mist erzählt, aber das eins auf jeden Fall interessant ist, dass diese Warnung Volk Kaspersky, die ja jetzt,
in der Lage ist, diesem Unternehmen nachhaltig zu schaden, so wie sie veröffentlicht wurde und von den Medien weiter getragen wurde. Ähm,
Offenbar drei Jahre später passiert oder zweieinhalb Jahre später passiert.
Und ich finde's auch amüsant, wie immer wieder, offenbar Geheimdienste das völlig normal finden, irgendwo drin zu hängen. Also wir nehmen das ja auch völlig in Ordnung wahr und sagen
Oh, oh, ey, pass auf mit dem Kaspersky da hängen, da hängen die Russen drin. Woher weißt du das? Ja, die Israelis haben hängen da auch drin und die haben die Russen bemerkt. Alter, also wem soll ich denn jetzt hier noch,
Wem soll ich denn jetzt hier noch vertrauen?
Wem soll man schon vertrauen, ja?
Also wer ich würde mal so sagen, wer wer NSA Myware entdecken möchte, nimmt Kaspersky, muss aber mit dem Risiko leben, dass FSB Mossad und NSA sowieso schon drinnen hängen.
Unglaublich. Ja, mal schauen, wie sich das noch weiter entwickelt.
So, jetzt haben wir ein paar lustige Meldungen gehabt. Jetzt äh machen wir, müssen wir nochmal schnell die Kurve kriegen zu ein paar echt äh fürchterlichen Meldungen.
Update zu den äh zehn verhafteten Personen in Istanbul. Ähm unter ihnen äh Peter Steudtner.
Der deutsche Aktivist der in einem Workshop ähm in Istanbul den Workshop-Besuchern erklärt hat, wie sie Dateien verschlüsseln können und dem deswegen nun vorgeworfen wird, er habe äh terroristische Organisationen unterstützt,
Da ist ein bisschen Bewegung reingekommen in den Fall, denn es wurde jetzt die Anklageschrift veröffentlicht
und die Hoffnung ist nun, dass die Veröffentlichung der Anklageschrift ein Zeichen auf Beschleunigung der Behandlung dieses Falles ist, denn Deniz Jükschell, der ja schon über zweihundert Tage in türkischer Haft ist, hat noch keine Anklageschrift.
Also verhaltene, positive
Betrachtung der Tatsache, dass hier eine Anklageschrift äh veröffentlicht wurde. Ähm es wurde außerdem auch gemeldet, die Staatsanwaltschaft fordere fünfzehn Jahre. Das geht aus der Anklageschrift nicht hervor. Also wir werden mal sehen, was sie dann machen werden.
Ähm aber man könnte also jetzt hoffen, dass in diesem Fall etwas Beschleunigung kommt und wir bleiben dann natürlich am Ball. Währenddessen wurde Anfang Oktober
die beiden,
Aktivisten, Peter und Ali von die also von waren, von zu Helden der Menschenrechte und,
Kommunikationsüberwachung gekürt. Ähm ich vermute, dass äh das eine schlechte Übersetzung ist.
Das klingt auch gerade ein bisschen äh.
Ich also die die.
Nee, das äh also auch das Original äh lautet tatsächlich so.
Heroes äh.
Und dann werden.
Andere sind die Willens of Communications.
Ja, ja, also von daher.
Also Ali Gharawi aus Schweden, Peter Steudtner aus äh Deutschland sieht also jetzt zu den Helden ähm,
gekürt wurden. Neben ihnen auch andere aus äh Mexiko, aus äh aus den USA. Ähm nun ja,
aber,
Wenn es da Verhaltene Hoffnung gibt, es ist echt krass, dass wir für ein digitales Sicherheitstraining in der Türkei, für nunmehr hundert Jahre äh hundert Tage auf ohne Anklageschrift,
landen kannst und äh kann also nur hoffen, dass da jetzt mal irgendwie langsam ein bisschen Bewegung reinkommt und diese Leute da endlich aus dem Knast rauskommen,
und mit Ihnen natürlich auch die acht weiteren von Amnesty International und was ja nicht alles.
Türkei geht derzeit echt überhaupt nicht.
Aber äh bei der bei der Türkei haben wir ja wenigstens noch die den Hebel der EU Beitrittsverhandlungen. Bei Malta haben wir den nicht.
Ja.
In Malta wurde jetzt eine Bloggerin getötet äh und zwar Daphne,
Galicia. Ähm die hat Anfang zwanzig sechzehn,
darüber berichtet, dass zwei zentrale Mitarbeiter des Premierministers Josef Muskat.
Finanzoperation getätigt hatten. Und ähm kurz darauf in der Veröffentlichung der Panama Papers wurde das auch äh bestätigt. Ne, also von unabhängigen Forschern.
Die hat sich in Pana äh in Panama sage ich schon, in in Malta mit äh.
Dem Wandel diese diese Staates von einem von einer beschaulichen Insel,
zu einem Steuerparadies mit entsprechenden mit entsprechender Geschäftigkeit auseinandergesetzt. Es ist irgendwie gerade mal hundert Kilometer von Sizilien entfernt. Sizilien, Italien, ne?
Und hat äh dort,
sich innerhalb kürzester Zeit zu einem innereuropäischen Steuerparadies entwickelt und wie gesagt, wenn du ein Steuerparadies ist, bist, dann ziehst du eben entsprechende,
Leute an, ne, also irgendwie äh siebzehn Prozent weniger Mehrwertsteuer auf die auf die Anschaffung einer Yacht, da,
Mafia schon mal auf den Gedanken, die Yacht dann eben auf Malta anzumelden. Der Finanzsektor ist imposant gewachsen, auch das klar, wenn du niedrige Steuern versprichst.
Und entsprechend Luxuswohnungen, neue Nachtlux und Hotels. Ähm ausländische Unternehmen äh,
kommen fünftausend Neue jedes Jahr auf der Insel nieder. Ansonsten hat Malta noch so schöne Angebote wie äh dass du einen maltesischen Pass für sechshundertfünfzigtausend Euro bekommst. Das heißt.
Für einen selbst.
Ja, also ich kann's dir mal kannst dir damit EU Staatsbürgerschaft kaufen, ne? Das macht den ja so, das macht den ja dann. Das treibt ja den Preis.
Ja
Also echt geil. Ähm.
Und ein Unternehmen dazu gründen, fünftausend pro Jahr lassen sich da nieder. Du brauchst ein Büro, eine lokale Sekretär oder Sekretärin und Buchhaltung fertig für die Form
einige Tage, ne, also Hürden bei der Anmeldung sehr niedrig und mittlerweile gibt es mehr als siebzigtausend registrierte Firmen
fünfhundertachtzig Investmentfonds, die von Malta aus operieren,
ähm oder so tun als ob. Achttausend davon sind italienisch, die meisten davon dubios, wett- und Spielbüros haben dort ihren Sitz, na ja und da hat diese Bloggerin also ähm,
mal so ein bisschen ihre Nase reingehalten und hat da innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch eben Verknüpfungen in den engsten Bereich des Premierministers gefunden und äh,
schrieb dann vor wenigen Tagen in ihrem Blog, äh resigniert, wo du auch hinschaust, überall sind Gauner, die Lage ist hoffnungslos. Wie verlässt kurz nach dem Post ihre Wohnung, steigt in ihr Auto?
Bombe, tot, Thema erledigt.
Ja, ist ja jetzt, wo das nochmal erwähnt hast, äh, erinnere ich mich auch, dass alles schon mal gelesen zu haben, also, dieses, äh, Reisepassangebot oder dieses Staatsbürgerschaftsangebot, das ist.
Thema Malta-Falz, die gab's ja auch, da hat sie dann auch dran mitgearbeitet.
Ist in bei Russen auch sehr beliebt, so.
Überall seine Finger.
Na ja, also nicht sicherlich nicht nur, aber äh vor allem auch, ne.
Nicht unbedingt so die Option für Flüchtlinge, weil die äh dürften dann Probleme haben, solche äh Beträge auf den Tisch zu legen, aber das ist natürlich dann für bestimmte Mitglieder der First Class in äh Russland äh ja,
Portokasse. Spart man sich ja dann beim Kauf einer Yacht.
Ich finde das, also es ist echt äh natürlich ein also es ist halt total krass, ne? Also eine eine Journalistin mit einer Autobombe zu töten in Europa.
Das ist schon echt äh.
Hochgradig mafiös, also meine ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir das aus Italien nicht auch äh kennen würden so, das ist jetzt in in diesem,
Gebiet nicht nicht unbedingt eine vollkommen neue Methode, nur war Malta bisher, nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt und der Zusammenhang ist natürlich hier auch relativ klar und lässt natürlich vermuten, dass das eben hier bis weit in die,
Ja. Staatsebene hineingreifen.
Also sie hatte natürlich äh sie wurden natürlich auch vorher ausführlich bedroht, ne? Und habe das auch äh ähm hat das ja also auch äh äh irgendwie erwähnt so und dann irgendwie ähm,
wurde natürlich auch von allen äh als als irgendwie fantasterei abgetan oder so, ne. Hm. Tja.
Übrigens hat sie nicht ihre Wohnung verlassen, sondern das Haus ihrer Familie. Lese ich, sehe ich gerade. Vor dem Haus der Familie ist sie dann in die Luft geflogen.
Ah, schon echt krass.
Linus, wir müssen Schluss machen. Ich muss.
Ja. Mir fällt da auch nicht mehr viel zu ein, ne. Also es ist irgendwie.
Übel. Aber Hauptsache, wir haben genug, uns über die Lügenpresse aufzuregen.
So denn.
Endet diese Sendung.
Dann sei Simon und Lars gedankt an dieser Stelle.
Mhm.
Wir melden uns bald wieder mit den schlechten Nachrichten der Woche.
Viel Spaß damit, tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.